uh very pleased to say that we're joined
once again on the programme by the
health secretary sergeant javed jacob
great to see you this morning um and of
course there is plenty to talk about in
terms of parties but let's let's start
on your briefing with that the changes
to the public health strategy clearly
there is an awful lot of concern in
government about the spread of omicron
right now
why are we so concerned well since we
first
of this new variant our strategy has
been to buy time time to assess it and
also to build our protective defenses in
recent days we've started learning more
about the variant and one of those
things we've learned is that it spreads
very very quickly it spreads faster than
any other code variant we've seen so far
it's doubling time that's the number of
days it takes the number of affections
take to double in the community
we estimate is between two and a half to
three days which would mean at that rate
by the end of this month we could hit
about a million infections in the
community uh throughout the uk and we've
always been clear that should the data
change and should should it move in the
wrong direction and and it looked like
that the nhs might come under
unsustainable pressure remember what
that would mean we wouldn't be able to
get emergency care not just for covert
you know give a car accident or anything
like that we would act and implement
plan b now i don't enjoy doing that no
one does you know it has a it's a very
difficult thing for many people asking
them to work from home or wearing face
busts and things so it's a it's a real
impact on our liberties but i hope that
most people will understand that by
taking some decisive action now we can
potentially avoid uh action later and
then just on that our vaccines and our
antivirals also remain a very important
part of our defenses the the key one i i
suspect in all that is potentially we do
not yet know whether or not the boosters
plus plan b
will in and of themselves be enough to
to halt the spread of omicron if they're
not what next look we we don't have all
the answers in omicron yet we've been
very clear about that's not just does us
throughout the world many countries are
still trying to learn more but what we
do know is by implementing plan b so the
rules around you know working from home
the the face mask rules the the rule
around the covert uh passport that that
will mean that we can slow uh the
incursion of this slow this is the
spread of this and it buys us time to
build our defenses and and that the
booster is key because although it's
possible and again it's possible that
the the efficacy of vaccines may be
impacted by omicron and there's some
data to suggest that it is still the
case that by boosting you're going to
get a lot more protection than otherwise
we're doing incredibly well as a country
with boosters over 20 million
it's all accepted but but it is the case
isn't it that over the christmas period
there will be increased mixing unless of
course there is a change to the plans
for christmas that is in and of itself
likely to lead to to increase spread
is it the case that you know come
january we could be looking at even more
significant measures being brought in no
i i hope not and i think the the action
we've taken now is very decisive i think
it's going to make a big difference and
as i say it's it's not something that
anyone would do likely has a real impact
on people will be difficult for many
people but i think that and i hope most
people uh will would understand is
better to take this action now uh than
to see the the rate of spread increase
it is the government considering
mandatory vaccination i mean the prime
minister did appear to hint at that when
he suggested a national conversation
about mandatory vaccinations what's the
truth of that no we've got i mean i've
got no interest in mandatory vaccination
apart from the high risk settings in the
nhs and social care which we've already
set out that we will legislate for uh
other than that if you talk about
universal mandatory vaccination i think
ethically it's wrong but also at a very
practical level it just wouldn't work
you know being getting vaccinated has to
be a positive decision it feels like we
can park that one then but just in terms
of the hospitality sector slightly away
from your brief but will we see
additional support for hospitality
because they are already starting to
lose money as a result of these plan b
changes well the measures we we've taken
in
under the you know the plan b uh
although they they have an impact
they're designed to have the a minimal
impact so whether it's wearing uh face
masks uh uh exempting hospitality from
certain measures on the kobe pass
there's this sounds like a no for more
financial support for well
we'll keep that under review but the the
measures are designed to have this
minimum impact
let us let us discuss the events of the
past couple of days we were expecting to
see you sitting in that chair yesterday
morning kay burley was very very upset
that you didn't appear
why wasn't there a government minister
on the media rounds yesterday well i i
didn't appear because i saw that video
the video you just played again
uh it upset me it upset a lot of people
i think across the country it upset the
prime minister did you refuse to come on
yesterday no it wasn't about refu i
spoke to my colleagues in number 10 and
i said look
we actually agreed that it's best to
have some time to to respond to the
video in the way the prime minister has
now by ordering an investigation by the
cabinet secretary and so i think the
idea was just to give them space to
react but i'm pleased the prime minister
has asked for an investigation and i and
i can see also why so many people would
have been upset by that video totally
but will you now be the first minister
to accept on a balance of probabilities
that an event probably did take place in
december on that date and that rules
were probably wrong the truth is i don't
know i i i the i have received
assurances like the prime minister has
that all rules will follow throughout
the pandemic at all times who is
providing those reassurances because we
have heard this from government
ministers sitting where you are all this
week we've heard it countless times from
the prime minister i have been told i
have been reassured who's saying well
i'm not i'm not going to get into names
but
senior people have assured me that rules
have been followed but i also think the
people wouldn't think to
the prime minister i think has acted uh
completely correctly yesterday to order
an investigation and to find out you
know what may or may not have happened
and to have that investigation done by
the cabinet secretary who's free to look
wherever he wishes speak to whoever he
wants and look at any potential event
that may or may not have happened but we
we saw the prime minister yesterday
pmq's accusing keir starman of playing
politics and all of this the prime
minister at any point over the last
seven days could have opened up the door
to his office popped outside asked
people what went on on that day and
discovered for themselves the reason he
hasn't done so you and i both know this
to be the case is that it's politically
expedient for the prime minister to not
know what went on in number 10 if that's
not playing politics with the situation
what it no i don't accept that and and
the reason is because what we heard from
the prime minister yesterday is that
he's asked for an investigation by the
cabinet secretary the campaign has a lot
of authority and he can speak to whoever
he wishes and find out what really
happened i think the best way to to to
look into this is to get the cabinet
secretary use all his authority to find
out what really but presumably the
cabinet secretary was one of those
reassuring the prime minister that no
rules had been broken i mean surely that
would have been the first person he
would have asked well i i i'm again i'm
not i was even in government at that
time so i don't know
who may have given the pm that
reassurance or not but i know i think it
is important of the this investigation
that's going on because he's either been
misled or someone has lied to him
because as you noted the video itself
pretty clearly demonstrates two very
senior figures in downing street one of
whom has now departed conceding that a
party took place accepting the fact that
rules were probably broken and more than
that then going on to war game a
potential response the video is prima
facie evidence that a party took place
i'm just wondering why the prime
minister is taking so long to reach that
conclusion i'm sure the cabinet
secretary would take into account what's
on that video the people that were in
that room at the time but it's right the
the cabinet secretary is given the time
to do that and get to the bottom of this
but but just in terms of that
investigation by the cabinet secretary
what what faith can any of us have that
the prime minister will follow the
results of that investigation the last
time there was an investigation by a
member of the senior
a senior member of the civil service the
head of ethics for the civil service
into pretty patel and bullying the prime
minister read it and then discarded it
well the
investigation is taking place i don't
want to preempt the outcome of it but i
know that your simon case is a very
professional very serious person
was the head of ethics for the service
but
let's see what comes out of the
investigation
there is a pattern of behavior here why
is the investigation only focusing on
the party that took place in downing
street on the 18th not the party that
took place on the 13th of november in
his flat not the party that took place
in november the 27th at which the prime
minister spoke the party that took place
at the department for education the
party that took place at cchq why is the
investigation only focused on the one
thing that the prime minister can
guarantee he wasn't attending it's not
my understanding is that simon case and
his team can look at any aspect any
potential event that may or may not have
happened at number 10 including
my understanding again is that he will
be looking into the uh what happened at
the department of education as well why
did allegra stratton resign
honestly i don't know and i i i do know
allegra i think she's an outstanding uh
spokesperson she's done some fantastic
work on on the cop recently
at that conference
and i think just by listening to her
statement yesterday uh i think she felt
bad about you know what had happened and
and the way things looked well she
apologized for the joke on which basis
why is ed oldfield still in his point is
still in his position he was there he
was joking why is jacob rees-mogg still
leader of the house he was joking and
the
institute for fiscal studies event that
happened the past couple of days
look i i think that we should just let
this investigation happen and and get to
the facts and simon case is the person
to do that do you not understand though
that the level of frustration that there
is in this government at the moment
because on the one hand we have been
told for over a week now that no party
took place yesterday downing street
refused to repeat that denial the only
thing that has changed is that video has
emerged which shows that a party took
place and that rules were broken that is
the only thing that has changed i mean
are you taking the public for fools in
all of this the reason presumably
allegra stratton resigned it's not
because of the joke but because the
government has been caught in the
cover-up i i just said to you at the
start of this
but you asked me why didn't i appear why
wasn't i sitting here yesterday it's
because i saw that video
i found it very upsetting uh to to see
what was on that video that they're
laughing they're sniggering and things i
think most people did across the country
and and and that's the way i reacted and
now the prime minister has reacted by
asking for an investigation i'm pleased
he's done that but of course of course i
understand
how people feel what they might think
and what they're seeing and i do think
we need to get to the bottom of it and
the way to do that is to have this
investigation that the cabinet secretary
is leading do you though accept that
there is a real problem in terms of
trust in this government the simple fact
is that no one believes you no one
believes you when you say that there was
no party number 10 not you specifically
but the government that no rules were
broken fewer than one in 10 believe
number 10's claimed that no party took
place in downing street and this follows
on from a number of other occasions over
the past 12 24 months where the
government have said x is going to
happen and then it doesn't or promise
why and then it doesn't appear i mean
the list of occasions on which this
government has performed a u-turn free
school meals the reopening of primary
schools mandatory face coverings and
shops face mastering schools a levels
second lockdown furlough extension
cancelling a christmas the northern
ireland protocol vaccine passport you've
performed a u-turn in all of this isn't
it
objectively reasonable for people now to
distrust everything that this government
i think honestly i think it's it's
unfair to really conflate all of that i
understand the anger about the video as
i've i've
shared with you my own anger and concern
about that but the the other issues that
you mentioned i mean these are all
important issues but you know for
example you just mentioned you know
covered passports or
face masks and things it is right that
we have a flexible response uh to the
pandemic all of this when i made your
job
when things have uh improved the
pandemic as we saw we made the right
decisions to open up in the summer we've
been really fortunate as a country with
the work the nhs has done around our
vaccination effort fantastic effort
we've got more people vaccinating most
other countries but all of this doesn't
make you successful
well i'm just i'm getting on with my job
and the important thing is right here
and now as far as i'm concerned is that
the pandemic is still there uh we need
to keep boosting and building our
defenses we need to learn more about new
variants and we need to make the
difficult decisions to help protect the
country and that's what i'm going to be
focused on and can i just finally say if
i made and if if any of your viewers if
they get the call from the nhs to get
vaccinated particularly the booster you
know please please turn up and roll up
your sleeve and get protected well we
saw the efforts that you went to with
john craig i'm sure the public will be
paying he's well boosted indeed uh he'll
secretary thanks for joining thank you